Russia is burning through ammunition in
Ukraine it means Russian industry is
under pressure to produce more
now claims have emerged that Moscow is
also receiving help from a close Ally
a source alleges that two ships
transported a large amount of ammunition
in January from Iran to Russia paid for
in cash
Security Source told me the two ships
are thought to have been carrying up to
a hundred million bullets and around 300
000 shells of varying sizes for
different weapons like machine guns
grenade launchers mortars it's not been
possible independently to verify the
volume and one expert said it did sound
quite high but Iran is certainly
suspected of supplying an amount of
ammunition To Russia to help replenish
stockpiles that are thought to be
running low
Sky News is data and forensics unit
looked into the movement of the two
Russian ships that were named by the
source as the Musa Jalil and the bege
on the 9th of January marine traffic
data show them in the Iranian Port of
amirabad on the Caspian Sea
this satellite image is taken the
following day
one of the ships the massage allele seen
here is likely turning to leave the port
later the other ship beg a and now Musa
Jalil appear to have left and are
traveling north towards the Russian
Coast
on the 12th of January both vessels
appear to stop in Turkmenistan Waters
this is the Musa Jaleel scene from a
satellite image
the reason they stop here is unknown by
the 27th of January they've reached the
Russian Port of Astra Khan the vessels
can be seen here and here in this
satellite image taken on the 2nd of
February
Sky News hasn't been able independently
to verify what they were carrying
Ukraine's ambassador to the UK says he's
not surprised about the ammunition
claims given that Iran is already
supplying Russia with deadly drones
this is a sort of a coalition of of the
weak Nations trying to you know to
considerate their last efforts to
withstand the pressure of much bigger
Western support which Ukraine is is
quite happy to have
but it's also a way for two allies
sanctioned by the West to help each
other
this has been a calculated Choice made
by Tehran and a choice that really
signals that the Islamic Republic is not
looking to transform or moderate but
actually is looking to survive and is
going to use this relationship to embed
the Islamic Republic and transform the
Islamic Republic going forward
with the war in Ukraine raging on its
high stakes for Russia to
asked about the ammunition claims the
Russian defense Ministry and Iran's
foreign Ministry have yet to give a
response